ON THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER.
AND THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION DID NOT FIND THAT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN ANYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH IT CONSPIRED OR
COORDINATED WITH RUSSIA IN THE
2016 U.S. PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT IS ROBERT MUELLER'S
CONCLUSION AFTER NEARLY TWO
YEARS OF INVESTIGATING THE
MATTER.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL REPEATED
VERSIONS OF THAT SENTENCE FOUR
TIMES IN HIS SUMMARY OF
MUELLER'S REPORT.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF DONALD
TRUMP, IT'S NOT FACTUALLY
ESTABLISHED THAT HE DID NOT
COLLUDE WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN TO
STEAL THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION,
PERIOD.
THAT CASE IS NOW CLOSED.
THIS IS THE POINT IN THE STORY
WHERE APPLAUSE BREAKS OUT.
NOT JUST CHEERS FROM TRUMP AND
HIS FAMILY AND CAMPAIGN STAFF
AND ALL OF THOSE MANY PEOPLE
THAT WERE TOLD THEY WOULD BE
INDICTED BUT WEREN'T.
BUT GRATITUDE FROM THE COUNTRY
ITSELF, FROM ALL AMERICANS.
FOR YEARS WE'VE ALL BEEN TOLD
OUR GOVERNMENT WAS BEING
CONTROLLED BY A FOREIGN POWER.
THERE WERE SPIES IN OUR MIDST,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WAS ONE OF THEM,
DISLOYAL, AN AGENT OF A NATION A
HATES US AND SEEKS OUR
DESTRUCTION.
THAT MAN WAS AT THE HELM OF OUR
COUNTRY, UNDERMINING OUR VALUES,
POISONING THIS NATION FROM
WITHIN.
HE WAS TERRIFYING.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WERE
TERRIFIED.
SOME WEPT AS THEY TALKED ABOUT
THEIR FEAR AND HELPLESSNESS.
NONE OF THAT WAS TRUE.
YOU WOULD THINK THE RELIEF AT
LEARNING THIS WOULD BE OVER
POWERING LIKE FINDING OUT A
TERMINAL ILLNESS WAS A COLD.
THE LONG AND BITTER WAR HAS
ENDED.
WE'RE SAFE.
THAT IS NOT HOW MOST ON THE LEFT
ARE RESPONDING TONIGHT.
THEY'RE NOT CELEBRATING FOR
THEIR COUNTRY.
THEY'RE ANGRIER THAN EVER.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION HAS
EXONERATED NO ONE AND PROVED
NOTHING.
RUSSIAN COLLUSION IS AS REAL TO
THEM IS IT WAS THE FIRST DAY
HILLARY CLINTON ALLEGED IT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY FIGHTS ON
AS IF NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
>> THE FACT THAT THIS
INVESTIGATIONTATION PLACE IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHICH DONALD
TRUMP CONTROLS AND HE GOT RID OF
THE ONE PROBLEM, JEFF SESSIONS
WHO RECUSED HIMSELF, THIS PHI IS
NOT RECUSED, FEELS LIKE THE
SEEDS OF A COVER-UP ARE HERE.
>> Tucker: OH, A COVER-UP.
NOT JUST A COVER UP BUT A COVER
UP BEING PERPETUATED BY
MR. ROBERT MUELLER, THE MAN THAT
YOU LOVED AND TRUSTED, THE ONE
WHOSE REPORT YOU LOOKED FORWARD
TO LIKE CHRISTMAS.
OUR FRIEND, ROBERT MUELLER.
IT TURNS OUT MUELLER WAS PART OF
THIS CONSPIRACY TOO.
IT WAS A CONSPIRACY SO
BRILLIANT, SO COMPLEX THAT HE
AND 18 OTHER FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
CONDUCTED A TWO-YEAR
INVESTIGATION IN ORDER TO SHIELD
THEIR PLOT FROM DISCOVERY.
DIABOLICAL.
WHY WOULD MUELLER DO THAT?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS THE SAME ANSWER.
ROBERT MUELLER IS A RACIST.
>> LOOK, IF I'M THE TRUMP
CHILDREN, I'M HAVING A PARTY
TONIGHT.
THEY WON THE WHITE PRIVILEGE
REGATTA.
YOU CANNOT -- THERE'S NOT AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN PERSON IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED FOR 22 MONTHS, HAD
THEIR FAMILY INVESTIGATED AND
COME AWAY SCOT-FREE.
>> A RACIST PLOT.
THAT'S WHAT NBC IS TELLING YOU.
IF THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
FAR-FETCHED CLAIM, KEEP IN MIND
YOU'RE THE WACKO.
YOU'RE A CONSPIRACY NUT.
YOU BELIEVE IN CRAZY THINGS.
YOU THINK THE LEFT IS COMING FOR
YOUR GUNS.
YOU THINK MASS IMMIGRATION IS
HURTING THIS COUNTRY.
YOU THINK ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE
VOTING IN I COLLECTIONS.
YOU IMAGINE THE TECH COMPANIES
ARE CENSORING POLITICAL SPEECH.
YOU DON'T TRUST THE MEDIA.
BY THE WAY, YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
SCIENCE AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
HESITANT TO GIVE A 29-YEAR-OLD
MEMBER OF CONGRESS COMPLETE
CONTROL OF THE U.S. ECONOMY.
YOU'RE A LUNATIC.
YOU SHOULD BE IGNORED.
SO SHOULD TRUMP.
IGNORE HIS COMPLAINTS ABOUT
BEING PERSECUTED.
HE'S JUST WHINING.
HERE'S NBC SUGGESTING THAT IT'S
DONALD TRUMP, THE GUY WHO HAS
BEEN FALSELY DENOUNCED FROM
BETRAYING HIS COUNTRY, WHO OWES
THE APOLOGY.
AN APOLOGY TO THE PROSECUTORS
THAT HOUNDED HIM.
>> DID ROBERT MUELLER DESERVE
BETTER FROM THE PRESIDENT?
THIS KIND OF LANGUAGE AND
BEHAVIOR?
>> HE TRASHED HIM FOR TWO YEARS.
IN THE END, MUELLER JUST DID AN
INVESTIGATION THAT ULTIMATELY
THE PRESIDENT CONSIDERS A TOTAL
EXONERATION OF HIM.
DOES HE OWE ROBERT MUELLER AN
APOLOGY FOR THAT KIND OF
RHETORIC?
>> IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ECHOED THESE SENTIMENTS OR MAYBE
THE OTHER WAY AROUND, THE MEDIA
HATING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SUDDENLY IT'S HARD TO TELL WHO
IS TAKING CUES FROM WHOM?
REPORTERS USED TO BOAST ABOUT
HOLDING THE POWERFUL TO ACCOUNT.
NOW THEY SCRAMBLE TO DO THEIR
BIDDING.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS OWNED
BY THE RICHEST PROGRESSIVE IN
THE WORLD.
THEY'RE ONE INTEREST GROUP NOW.
POLITICIANS AND PROSECUTORS AND
INTEL AGENCY HEADS TOLD US
IMPLAUSIBLE LIES ABOUT RUSH
COLLUSION.
REPORTERS ARE PAID TO PUSH BACK.
THEY DID.
THEY WELCOMED THE LIES AND
AMPLIFIED THEM.
THEY'RE NOT APOLOGIZING FOR IT
NOW.
IN THE FIRST STATEMENT AFTER THE
MUELLER REPORT BECAME PUBLIC,
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER,
THE TWO LEADERS OF THE DEMOCRAT,
DIDN'T MENTION THE FACT THAT
TRUMP HAD BEEN CLEARED OF
COLLUSION.
NEITHER DID ANY DEMOCRATIC POLL
SITUATION APPEARING ON CABLE
NEWS.
VIRGINIA CONGRESSMAN DON BAYERN
SAID THERE WAS A LOT OF
COLLUSION IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
EVEN THOUGH ROBERT MUELLER TOLD
US OTHERWISE.
SO NOBODY WAS FOOLED BY ANY OF
THIS.
MUELLER'S SUMMARY IS ON THE
INTERNET.
YOU CAN READ IT YOURSELF IF YOU
WANT AND REACH YOUR OWN
CONCLUSIONS.
SO BY LYING ABOUT THE OBVIOUS,
DEMOCRATS REVEALED THEMSELVES TO
BE WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS, STUPID,
IRRESPONSIBLE, RECKLESS,
CORRUPT.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO
SAY.
OVER ON CNN, JEFF ZOOKER, SAID
YOU MAY THINK CNN HAS BEEN
WHINING TOO RELENTLESSLY THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
NOT AT ALL.
CNN HAS DONE A FANTASTIC JOB.
NONE OF THIS WAS OUR FAULT.
WE'RE AMAZING.
LISTEN TO HIM SQUEAK.
>> REPORTING IS WHAT ADDS THE
MOST VALUE.
FINDING OUT SOMETHING NEW,
PUTTING OUT NEW INFORMATION INTO
THE WORLD IS THE BEST FEELING IN
JOURNALISM.
IT'S THE GREATEST VALUE ADD.
THAT'S WHAT HUNDREDS OF
JOURNALISTS HAVE BEEN DOWNING,
TRYING TO SOLVE PIECES OF THIS
TRUMP-RUSSIA PUZZLE.
DON'T BE FOOLED BY THE PARTISANS
THAT CHERRY PICKED THE TWOS
MISTAKES OF INDIVIDUAL
JOURNALISTS OR THE CRAZIEST
IDEAS FROM COMMENTATORS AND
CLAIM THAT'S THE ENTIRE MEDIA.
IT'S NOT.
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE FACTS.
HERE'S WHAT I KNOW.
YOU'LL HEAR THIS FROM THE RIGHT
THE NEXT DAYS AND WEEKS TO COME
AS THE PRESS HAS MADE THIS UP TO
TAKE DOWN PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PRESS IS FOLLOWING A TRAIL
THAT TRUMP CREATED.
>> Tucker: THE GREATEST VALUE
ADD.
THAT'S HOW CNN SUMS UP ITS ROLE
IN THE RUSSIA STORY.
DOES A SINGLE PERSON BELIEVE
THAT?
OF COURSE NOT.
NOT ONE PERSON.
JEFF ZOOKER HIMSELF DOESN'T
BELIEVE IT.
HE'S AN ANXIOUS MAN TONIGHT.
HE'S BEEN CAUGHT DOING THE ONE
THING JOURNALISTS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO DO.
HI MISLED HEAD AUDIENCE.
IN A FAIR WORLD, HE WOULD BE
RUNNING A CAR WASH OR SELLING
TIME SHARES IN CANCUN.
HE WOULDN'T BE IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS.
HE KNOWS THAT VERY WELL.
HE KNOWS HE'S AN IMPOSTER.
IN 1996, CNN BLAMED THE OLYMPIC
BOMBINGS IN ATLANTA ON AN
ENTIRELY INNOCENT SECURITY GUARD
NAME RICHARD JEWELL.
IN THE END, THEY PAID HIM A
SETTLEMENT FOR SLANDER.
AND THEN THEY ACCUSED THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY OF MURDERING OF
SARIN GAS.
THEY RAN THE STORY ANYWAY AFTER
THEY KNEW IT WAS FALSE.
AND THEN AFTER ZERO EVIDENCE
THAT A CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN
GARY CONDITT MURDERED AN INTERN.
THEY HELPED DRIVE HIM FROM
OFFICE.
HE TURNED OUT TO BE INNOCENT.
TOO LATE.
HIS LIFE AND FAMILY WERE
DESTROYED.
YOU'D THINK A NEWS NETWORK MIGHT
LEARN FROM DEBACLES LIKE THIS.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF JEFF
ZOOKER, THEIR DISHONESTY HAVE
ACCELERATED.
THEY SAID THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
WAS A GANG RAPIST ALCOHOLIC THAT
TARGETED UNDERAGE GIRLS.
IN JANUARY, THEY TOLD US A GROUP
OF CATHOLIC BOYS FROM KENTUCKY
WERE BIGOTS THAT THREATENED TO
REVERE TRIBAL ELDER BECAUSE THEY
HATED AMERICAN INDIANS.
EVERY PART OF THE CLAIM WAS A
LIE AND CNN IS FACING A $275
MILLION LAWSUIT FOR REPEATING
THAT LIE.
CNN KEPT GOING.
JUST DAYS AFTER ITS COVINGTON
CATHOLIC FRAUD, THEY DESIDED TO
AMPLIFY ANOTHER RACIALLY
DIVISIVE HOAX.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT'S HATE CRIME.
NOW WE LEARN THAT THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION NARRATIVE, WHICH BY
THE WAY HAS FORMED THE BACKBONE
OF CNN'S ENTIRE PROGRAMMING
SCHEDULE FOR TWO YEARS, IS FAKE.
IT'S A HOAX.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
CNN RESPONDED BY CONGRATULATING
ITSELF.
JEFF ZOOKER STILL RUNS THE
NETWORK.
HIS JOB IS SAFE.
CNN'S ANCHORS WONDER WHY
AMERICANS DON'T TRUST THE NEWS
MEDIA.
MUST BE THE PROPAGANDA FROM FOX
NEWS.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH COVERAGE
LIKE THIS.
>> BIG NEW QUESTIONS IN THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION AND THE
LACK OF ANSWERS FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> ANY KIND OF COLLUSION WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
>> AND THEN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
>> WE KNOW THE RUSSIANS WERE
INVOLVED WITH INTERFERING WITH
THE ELECTION.
>> HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THE
MANAFORT ALLEGATIONS?
>> IT'S ON THE QUESTION OF
COLLUSION, POSSIBLE COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA.
>> FACT.
IT'S RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: FACT, IT'S RUSSIA!
OKAY.
THANKS FOR THAT, MR. LEMON.
WHAT ARE THESE VOICES SAYING NOW
ON CNN, THAT THE FACTS HAVE
ARRIVED?
HAVE THEY APOLOGIZED OR
CORRECTED THEMSELVES OR
ACKNOWLEDGED THEIR ROLL IN
PERPETUATING THIS HOAX?
LET'S SEE.
HERE'S CARL BERNSTEIN WHOSE
SLOPPY WATERGATE REPORTING FROM
HALF A CENTURY AGO.
HE SAID HE THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT
THIS QUESTION.
HE DECIDED THAT IN HIS SEASONED
OPINION AS A NEWSMAN, CNN DID A
REMARKABLE JOB HERE.
>> I THINK WE DONE THE MEDIA,
THE PRESS HAS DONE ONE OF THE
GREAT REPORTING JOBS IN THE
HISTORY OF SPECIALLY OF COVERING
A PRESIDENCY BY THE MOST NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS.
LOOK, LET'S LOOK AT WHERE THE
DISINFORMATION AND MISTAKES AND
LIES HAVE COME FROM.
HASN'T COME FROM THE PRESS.
IT'S COME FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THOSE
AROUND HIM.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING, AND
YOU MAY BE, WHY DONALD TRUMP GOT
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, YOU JUST SAW IT.
TRUMP MAY BE FLAWED, BUT THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE ARE JUST
ABSURD.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" HAVE NO IDEA.
THEY STILL DON'T KNOW WHY TRUMP
WON THE ELECTION.
THEY WHOLE HEARTEDLY AGREE WITH
THEIR FRIEND, CARL BERNSTEIN.
BOTH OF HIS PAPERS WON PULITZER
PRIZES FOR THEIR RUSSIA REPORTS.
>> Tucker: READ THAT RUN-ON
SENTENCE AGAIN, IF YOU DARE.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO KEEP THOSE
WORDS AS A KEEPSAKE MOMENTUM
LIKE THAT DEWEY DEFEATS TRUMAN.
YOUR GRANDKIDS CAN READ IT AND
SNICKER.
THE TIMES HAVE NO PLAN TO RETURN
THEIR PRIZES.
THEY DID THEY DID A GREAT JOB.
THE REST OF US CAN KEEP
LAUGHING.
THERE'S AN OMINOUS LESSON HERE,
TOO.
OUR LEADERS ARE NOT FIT TO LEAD.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND THEY WON'T ADMIT IT.
THEY'RE HYSTERICAL CHILDREN,
CRUEL AND STUPID AND VAIN.
THEY CARE ONLY ABOUT THEMSELVES.
THEY LEARN NOTHING FROM THEIR
MISTAKES.
SO THEIR SELF-REGARD, THEY MARCH
ON TO THE NEXT DISASTER FULL OF
SELF-RIGHTEOUS CONFIDENCE.
THE NEXT BATTLE IS OVER
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
DOESN'T SEEM TO OCCUR TO THEM
THAT JUSTICE IS PRECISELY WHAT
WE GOT YESTERDAY.
19 FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
INVESTIGATED THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY'S CLAIM THAT DONALD TRUMP
STOLE THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
INVESTIGATORS IN THE CASE HAD TO
LIMITLESS BUDGET AND NO
RESTRICTIONS.
THEY HIRED DOZENS OF ANALYSTS
AND ACCOUNTANTS TO HELP THEM
INVESTIGATE.
THEY ISSUED 3,000 SUBPOENAS.
THEY RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF SEARCH
WARRANTS.
THEY SHOWED UP WITH PEOPLE'S
HOMES WITH AUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
THEY SPADE ON AMERICAN CITIZENS,
READ THEIR TEXTS, DOWNLOADED
E-MAILS.
THEY INTERVIEWED AT LEAST 500
SEPARATE WITNESSES.
NOT SINCE SEPTEMBER 11th HAVE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS DUG MORE
DEEPLY INTO A CASE.
IN THE END, THEY PROVED THE
CHARGES FALSE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE DECIDED TO IGNORE
THE FINDINGS.
INSTEAD THEY SAY THEY WANT
JUSTICE BY WHICH THEY MEAN
REVENGE, PUNISHMENT, POWER.
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE ALWAYS
WANTED.
THE REST OF THIS, THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION INCLUDED, WAS
STAGED FOR SHOW.
SHAME ON THE REST OF US FOR
FALLING FOR IT YET AGAIN.
YOU'D LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT
PEOPLE THAT DID THIS WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY HURT OUR COUNTRY, POISONED
OUR PUBLIC'S FEAR AND DISTORTED
OUR FOREIGN POLICY, TERRIFIED
THE POPULATION.
THEY SHOULD BE PUNISHED.
IT'S NOT LIKE WE DON'T PUNISH
PEOPLE HERE.
WE LIVE IN A SOCIETY FOR PEOPLE
LOSE THEIR JOBS FOR BELIEVING IN
BIOLOGY.
COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE THEIR
LIVES AT RISK FOR TELLING THE
WRONG JOKE.
AMERICA IS SUDDENLY A PUNITIVE
PLACE.
THESE PEOPLE WILL ESCAPE WHAT
THEY DESERVE.
THEY SO OFTEN HAVE BEFORE.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT PUSHED THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION CONSPIRACY ARE
THE ONES THAT SAID THAT SADDAM
HUSSEIN HAD WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
THEY SAID THE HOUSING SITUATION
WAS SOLID.
INVEST.
NOW THEY SAID WE'LL HAVE TO STAY
IN SYRIA AND AFGHANISTAN FOREVER
BECAUSE OF THREATS THAT ONLY
THEY UNDERSTAND.
TOMORROW THEY'LL BE TELLING YOU
TO TAKE THE BUS TO WORK BECAUSE
OF GLOBAL WARMING.
THEY WILL NEVER TAKE THE BUS.
THEY WON'T HAVE TO.
THEY WILL NEVER FACE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE DISASTERS
THEY CREATED.
INSTEAD, THEY KEEP GETTING RICH
FROM FAILURE.
ANOTHER TV CONTRACT, ANOTHER FAT
GRANT FROM A SORROS FUNDED
FOUNDATION.
THEY CONTINUE TO LECTURE YOU
ABOUT YOUR IMAGINARY MORAL
FAILINGS.